(Música)
O Orión, el cazador.
O incluso Tauro, el toro.
(Música)
Vivimos en un universo musical,
y podemos usar eso para experimentarlo
desde una nueva perspectiva,
y compartir esa perspectiva con un rango de gente mayor.
Déjenme mostrárselo.
(La música termina)
Cuando digo a la gente que soy astrofísico,
suelen impresionarse bastante.
Entonces digo que también soy músico
dicen "Sí, sí, lo sabemos".
(Risas)
Todo el mundo parece saber
que hay esta conexión profunda entre música y astronomía.
Y es una idea muy antigua;
Se remonta a hace más de 2000 años, a Pitágoras.
Quizá recuerde a Pitágoras por teoremas como
el teorema pitagórico,
(Risas)
Y él dijo:
"Hay geometría en el murmullo de las cuerdas,
hay música en el espacio de las esferas".
Y literalmente, pensó:
que los movimientos de los planetas
a lo largo de la esfera celeste
crearon música armoniosa.
Y si le hubiera preguntado: "¿Por qué no oímos nada?"
el diría que no puede oírlo
porque no sabe lo que no es oírlo;
no sabemos qué es el auténtico silencio.
Como cuando necesita que la electricidad se vaya
para oír lo fastidioso que era su refrigerador.
Quizás lo crea,
pero no todo el mundo lo cree, incluyendo nombres
como Aristóteles.
(Risas)
Palabras exactas.
Parafrasearé sus palabras exactas.
Dijo que es una buena idea,
pero si algo tan grande y vasto como los cielos mismos
se movían y hacían sonidos,
no solo serían audibles,
Sería un sonido terriblemente fuerte.
Existimos, por lo tanto, no hay música en las esferas.
También pensó que el único propósito del cerebro
era enfríar la sangre,
así que...
(Risas)
Pero me gustaría mostrarles que, de alguna manera,
ambos tenían razón.
Empezaremos entendiendo qué hace a la música musical.
Puede sonar como una pregunta tonta,
pero, ¿se ha preguntado por qué
ciertas notas, al tocarse juntas, suenan relativamente agradables
o consonantes,
como estas dos...
(Música)
mientras otras, muchos más tensas o disonantes,
como estas dos?
(Música)
¿Verdad?
¿Por qué es esto? ¿Por qué hay notas?
¿Por qué puedes estar dentro o fuera de tono?
La respuesta a esa pregunta
fue resuelta por el propio Pitágoras.
Echen un vistazo a la cuerda en el extremo izquierdo
Si tensa esa cuerda,
producirá una nota que oscila muy rápido ida y vuelta.
(Nota musical)
Pero al cortar la cuerda por la mitad, se obtendrán dos cuerdas,
cada una oscilará dos veces más rápido.
Y producirá una nota relacionada
O tres veces más rápido,
o cuatro veces...
(Notas musicales)
Y así el secreto de la armonía musical son ratios simples:
cuanto más simple el ratio,
más agradables o consonantes sonarán esas dos notas juntas.
Y cuanto más complejo el ratio, más disonantes sonarán.
Y es una interacción entre tensión e interacción,
o consonancia y disonancia,
que crea lo que llamamos música.
(Música)
(La música acaba)
(Aplausos)
Gracias.
Pero hay más.
(Risas)
Las dos características de la música
que nos gusta pensar como tono y ritmos,
son, de hecho, dos versiones de la misma cosa,
y puedo mostrárselo.
(Ritmo lento)
Eso era un ritmo, ¿no?
Mire que pasa cuando lo aceleramos.
(El ritmo se vuelve gradualmente más rápido)
(Tono alto)
(Bajando el tono)
(Ritmo lento)
Pero una vez que el ritmo se repite más de 20 veces por segundo,
su cerebro desconecta.
Deja de oírlo como un ritmo y empieza a oírlo como un tono.
¿Qué tiene que ver esto con la astronomía?
Ahí es cuando llegamos al sistema TRAPPIST-1.
Este es un sistema exoplanetario descubierto el pasado febrero
de 2017,
y todos se emocionaron
porque son 7 planetas del tamaño de la Tierra
orbitando una estrella enana roja cercana.
Y pensamos que tres de los planetas
tienen la temperatura para agua líquida.
Y están tan cerca que en los próximos años
deberíamos ser capaces de detectar
elementos en sus atmósferas
como oxígeno y metano, signos potenciales de vida.
Pero algo sobre el sistema TRAPPIST
es que es muy pequeño.
Aquí tenemos las órbitas del interior de los planetas rocosos
en nuestro sistema solar:
Mercurio, Venus, la Tierra y Marte,
y los 7 planetas del tamaño terrestre de TRAPPIST-1
están bien metidos en la órbita de Mercurio.
Tengo que expandir esto 25 veces
para que pueda ver las órbitas de los planetas TRAPPIST-1.
Es de hecho de un tamaño más similar
a nuestro planeta Júpiter y sus lunas,
aunque son siete planetas del tamaño de la Tierra
orbitando un estrella.
Otra razón por la que nos emocionó,
fueron las interpretaciones artísticas
Como esta.
Se obtiene algo de agua líquida, algo de hielo, tal vez tierra
tal vez pueda se pueda bucear en este increíble atardecer naranja.
Nos emocionó a todos,
y algunos meses después, salieron otros artículos.
Dicho esto, en realidad,
es probable que se parezca más a esto.
(Risas)
Así que había señales
de que alguna de las superficies podría ser lava fundida
y allí estaban los rayos-X perjudiciales procedentes
de la estrella central
rayos-X que esterilizarían la superficie de la vida
e incluso despejarían atmósferas.
Por suerte, hace apenas unos meses, en 2018,
se publicaron nuevos artículos con medidas más refinadas,
y encontraron que en realidad lucía como algo así.
(Risas)
Ahora sabemos que muchos de ellos tienen enormes suministros de agua
océanos globales ...
y varios de ellos tienen atmósferas espesas,
por lo que es el lugar adecuado para una potencial vida.
Pero hay algo aún mucho más emocionante de este sistema,
especialmente para mí.
Y eso es que TRAPPIST-1 es una cadena resonante.
Y significa que por cada dos órbitas del planeta exterior,
el siguiente órbitara tres veces,
y el siguiente cuatro,
y entonces 6, 9, 15 y 24.
Así ve muchos ratios muy simples entre las órbitas de esos planetas.
Claramente, si se acelera su movimiento
puedes conseguir ritmos, ¿no?
un ritmo, digamos, cada vez que un planeta da vueltas.
Ahora sabemos que si aceleramos el movimiento aún más
en realidad producirá tonos musicales,
y en este solo caso,
estos tonos trabajarán juntos,
creando armonías, incluso armonía humana.
Vamos a oír a TRAPPIST-1.
Lo primero que oirán será una nota por cada órbita de cada planeta,
y solo tengan en cuenta que
esta música proviene el propio sistema en sí.
No estoy creando tonos o ritmos,
Solo los estoy reduciendo al rango de audición humana.
Y después de que los 7 planetas han entrado,
va a ver...
oirán un tambor cada vez que dos planetas se alinean.
Ahí es cuando se acercan.
y se dan un tirón gravitacional.
(Tono)
(Dos tonos)
(Tres tonos)
(Cuatro tonos)
(Cinco tonos)
(Seis tonos)
(Siete tonos)
(Golpes de tambor)
(La música acaba)
Y ese es el sonido de la propia estrella, luz convertida en sonido.
Así que puede preguntarse cómo es esto incluso posible
Y es bueno pensar en la anología de una orquesta.
Cuando todos se juntan para empezar a tocar en una orquesta,
no pueden solo sumergirse en esto,
tienen que estar en sintonía;
tienen que asegurarse
de que sus instrumentos resuenan con sus instrumentos vecinos
y sucedió algo parecido con TRAPPIST-1
al principio de su existencia.
Cuando los planetas se formaron,
orbitaban dentro de un disco de gas,
y mientras estaban dentro de ese disco,
de hecho, pueden deslizarse
y ajustar sus órbitas con las de sus vecinos
hasta estar en perfecta sintonía.
Y es algo bueno, porque el sistema sería demasiado compacto,
mucha masa en un espacio muy reducido,
si cada aspecto de sus órbitas no estuviera muy afinado,
alterando muy rápido el resto de las órbitas,
destruyendo el sistema entero
Es realmente la música la que mantiene el sistema vivo
y de sus habitantes potenciales.
Pero, ¿cómo suena nuestro sistema solar?
Odio ser el que le muestre esto, pero no es bonito.
(Risas)
Por una cosa,
nuestro sistema solar está en una escala mucho más grande,
y su escuchaamos los ocho planetas,
comenzamos con Neptuno, cerca del límite inferior
del rango de audición,
entonces Mercurio va a ascender
cerca del rango más alto de audición.
Pero, como nuestros planetas no son tan compactos,
están muy extendidos,
no tienen que ajustar sus órbitas entre sí,
así que todos están tocando su propia nota aleatoria
en momentos aleatorios.
Así que, lo siento, pero aquí está.
(Tono)
Eso es Neptuno.
(Dos tonos)
Urano.
(Tres tonos)
Saturno.
(Cuatro tonos)
Júpiter.
Y entremetido, está Marte.
(Cinco tonos)
La Tierra
(Seis tonos)
Venus
(Siete tonos)
(Ocho tonos)
Y eso es Mercurio ...
Ok,Ok, paro.
(Risas)
Este era, de hecho, el sueño de Kepler.
Johannes Kepler es la persona
que averiguó las leyes del movimiento planetario.
Estaba completamente fascinado con esta idea
de que hay una conexión entre la música, astronomía y geometría.
Y él usó un libro completo
buscando cualquier tipo de armonía musical
en el sistema planetario solar
y fue muy, muy difícil.
Habría sido mucho más fácil si hubiera vivido en TRAPPIST-1
o para el caso...
K2-138.
Este es un nuevo sistema descubierto en enero de 2018
con cinco planetas,
y al igual que TRAPPIST,
desde el principio de su existencia todos estaban afinados.
Estaban sintonizados
en una estructura ajustable propuesta
por el propio Pitágoras,
hace más de 2000 años.
Pero el sistema es nombrado así por Kepler,
descubierto por el telescopio espacial Kepler.
Y en los últimos billones de años,
han perdido su sintonía,
un poco más que TRAPPIST,
y lo que vamos a hacer es retroceder en el tiempo
e imaginar cómo habrían sonado
cuando se estaban formando.
(Música)
(La música acaba)
(Aplausos)
Gracias.
Uds. pueden preguntarse: ¿Hasta dónde llega esto?
¿Cuánta música hay en realidad ahí fuera?
Y es lo que me preguntaba el pasado otoño
cuando trabajaba en el U del planetario T,
y contacté por un artista llamada Robyn Rennie
y su hija Erin.
A Robyn le encanta el cielo nocturno,
pero no ha podido verlo claramente durante 13 años
por su pérdida de visión.
Y se preguntaban si había algo que yo pudiera hacer.
Así coleccioné todos los sonidos que podía pensar del universo
y lo empaqueté en lo que se convirtió en
"Our Musical Universe".
Este es un espectáculo del planetario basado en sonido
explorando el ritmo y la armonía del cosmos.
Y Robyn estaba tan conmovida por la presentación
que cuando volvió a casa,
pintó esta maravillosa representación de su experiencia.
Y luego yo lo estropeé poniendo a Júpiter para el póster.
(Risas)
Así que ...
en este espectáculo, tomo personas de todos los niveles de visión
y los llevo en un paseo auditivo por el universo,
desde el cielo nocturno hasta el fin del borde
del universo observable.
Pero este es el comienzo de una odisea musical
para experimentar el universo con nuevos ojos y oídos,
y espero que se unan a mí.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)